There are few situations
more dangerous than
entering a burning
building. Thermoplastic
fire helmets weigh
substantially less than
other alternatives.
These helmets are one
piece of equipment that
won't slow down the
rescue mission.
Production starts with
the special blend of
thermoplastic pellets.
A vacuum pulls the
pellets into a hopper.
The pellets then flow
into an injection molding
machine. It melts and
molds the pellets into
the shape of a fire
helmet.
A robot retrieves the
helmet and transfers it
to a cooling station.
A worker then clips off
plastic that solidified
as it flowed through a
channel and into the
mold. This unwanted bit
is called sprue.
She wipes off
fingerprints and inspects
the condition of the
helmet shell.